we're sitting here drinking pumpkin
spice lattes from dim pumpkin spice
latte is bad and never drink it more of
a black coffee kinda guy I don't seem
right pumpkin and coffee your head
pumpkin pie no oh my god it's in a
mystery cup oh it's no sweet Cheers
hmm I can't taste pumpkin it's like
chocolate and pumpkin that's got my
daughter's written all over it
it's a good balance between pumpkin
spice and everything else and it's not
like a punch in your face of flavor and
artificial miss if we were scoring chai
lattes I would say three out of five
I like chai and I like pumpkin spice I
like sushi and I like nachos but I would
never have them together in one dish you
can't call something pumpkin if it's not
gonna taste like it I think this is
McDonald's entice it like an older
pumpkin so a more mature pumpkin hmm yes
lovely we'll take the bottle with
whiskey by a fire maked lying on a polar
bear Road just makes me want to adult
with coffee being number three Oh
[Music]
Aussies know there can't be genius
cheers to coffee bean although this
one's curdling whoa no that's just
probably cinnamon okay this one's really
orange it's nothing pumpkin if it's not
Starbuck everyone watching this video
can get a dollar from my bag okay
this tastes more like coffee than the
others it's really watery there's just
like weird ashy aftertaste
this is Staubach do you know what this
smells I icing on a beautiful cinnamon
cake it's tangy there's nothing more
coffee than there is yeah pumpkin spice
and keep drinking it not good on a lemon
see a guy fancy but I definitely smarter
grinded yeah this is good this looks
like it bad bad
I mean I'm happy coffee pump pump sugar
pump pump coffee is it McDonald's it's
all I've heard Americans talk about
since landing in this fine country
I'll be at coffee bean you can all leave
me alone in there with my Starbucks and
a pumpkin